over recent years international student
numbers have soared in Canada most of
them pay tuition fees double triple or
even higher than that compared to
domestic students this trend has come as
provincial funding for higher education
has faced repeated Cuts over recent
decades straining budgets but learning
institutions cannot raise domestic
doation without provincial approval and
now postsecondary institutions are
reacting sharply to Ottawa scap on
international student intake experts are
warning that the education sector could
see layoffs program closures and service
Cuts Philip Landon interim president of
universities Canada says while it's too
early to make predictions things don't
look good and if you remove um a revenue
stream uh significantly and you do not
increase it through the provincial
operating grants um you know something
is going to have to give and so we're
we're we're very concerned about what
might happen he's not alone either one
official at Toronto metropolitan
University warned that the move brings
Financial risks the Ontario
Confederation of University faculty
associations is also calling for an
annual funding increase of almost 12%
over 5 years to help International
students spend over $22 billion in the
Canadian economy every year according to
Federal data and last year the average
international student paid six times the
tuition of the average domestic student
without that kind of money coming in the
next chapter for colleges and
universities remains unclear
oana Global News Toronto